la violencia en Ecuador cada día es peor
principalmente en Guayaquil grupos
criminales se pelean por controlar el
negocio de las drogas en la ciudad más
grande del país volviendo comunes las
noticias de asesinatos tiroteos e
incluso casos de desmembramientos hechos
que afectan directamente a la población
civil y que serán decisivos para las
elecciones anticipadas del 20 de agosto
básicamente es
expuesta como parte de los daños
colaterales en el enfrentamiento entre
las organizaciones delictivas por un
lado y en algunos otros casos también
entre la delincuencia y las acciones que
realiza el gobierno para controlarla
solamente Guayaquil registró 1.390
muertes violentas durante el primer
semestre del 2023 pese a los esfuerzos
de las autoridades en Ecuador no es
nuevo el negocio de las drogas ilícitas
pero durante los últimos años el puerto
de Guayaquil se ha convertido en un
atractivo para diferentes carteles como
los provenientes de México o Albania
al inicio de organizaciones buscan
utilizar los puertos para eso utilizan
de ciertas técnicas que es la
contaminación a los contenedores la zona
ocho es un Distrito
muy complejo por la particularidad de
que tenemos aquí los puertos lo que hace
que las organizaciones los o las de gdo
vean como un punto estratégico acá a
Guayaquil es por eso que acá se ha
incrementado lo que son las muertes de
violentas en la lucha de las
organizaciones de los grupos de
delincuencia organizada en Guayaquil se
ha declarado el estado de excepción lo
que ha permitido el despliegue del
ejército y que los civiles usen armas en
defensa propia una problemática heredada
que tendrá que enfrentar quien quiera
llegar al palacio de carondelet tras las
elecciones anticipadas en Ecuador